ER
IN RE.
W THE CTF DELTE ANY CH
VARIANT  C
QU NNG HOMESF HEDULT LFACILIES
COUNY. S SPRINPAY ATNT
NOW.
LET ME SHOW YOU WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN HOMES
WE HAVE BEEN P THIS
IN TERMS,
ENTS ARE ANGLATION IN THE UN
STAFF CLOSER T%.Y TE
TIMES.D OMES, 3.6 TIMES.OUNTRY P
THEY'RE GROWING SLOWER
HACINATED
POPULATION BUT NOT ALLSING
HOMES ARE THE SAME AND THIS IS
ALLY HAD HIGHER
VAATHEED
50E WITH THE RG HOMES WHERE THE
COUNTRY, THEN IT WAS
ER
FASTER IOSMES ESOUNTRY
OKAY?
IF YOU LOO SPEFIC STATES,
WE CAN S
AGAIN, GO TOG HOME
OM FOR THEY. 8.4 TIMES FTEWE TO
ATTENTN  HOMES.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IING
WHAT'S HAPPENING THENTRY.
D THOSE NUG
T AREAHERE.
THIS QUESTION COMES FROM JIEIN O
THE CDC AND S
WITH BOTH HIGH VE
ANIDRARATE, R  I L SAN
H ERPOPULATION IR  RATE IN COVIS
INTERESTING POINT.FTOKAY, WE GO
VCIWHAT ELSE DO WE NEED TO DOO.
ONU WANT T
SURE PEOPLE AREN'TSTANTLBEING EE
SOMEE IF THE AS WERHI
FILTRATI5 ORTHREE WEEK COULD BRO
THREE EKTHATN EGO.T'
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.NE 60% FATEDUT
SOTHING
ATE WHERE THE CASEAR
>> THERE'S NO AMIT TT
GRC.>> WE KNOW WH ISOM
HT NOWN EGO.T MESSAGE, AT LEAST
THE XT WON RATES COME
WN, IF YOU LIVE IN AIGON, WEAR
S.O GLAD
THAT GPHID
INFECTIONS IF THEY'RE HR
SAME AS OTHER NS WHEN
YOU LOOK A
SO YOU REALLY WANT TO BREAK OUT
THOSE NUMBS TO OF, SOMEONE
NOT BE THAT WHITE PA GRAAS
SH S W
R SHE ALREY ET
>> J, S PRLY ONE OF
THE MOST COMMON QUESTIONS I  DO
THAT IS TRUE CELLS CALLED T.CELR
AND THERE'S  BY EXAMPLES WAD
STRONGER IMMUNY THAN WHAT A VAI.
ATUSE WE HAVE TH.
WET KNOW THIS AI BEGIN BHE TED T
VACCINES AREGOMORECOMING.ATHES
VACCINES ARE MORE DURABLE, LONGN
OAON AGAINST THE
VARI. HEAR, THEY CAN
HAVE THEIRAK TTHEIR VACCINANE EI
BOGO GET THE.TER  IS FROM'M FUL
INTOHO.
WHAT SHOULD I DO
AND DO I HAVE TORANTINE?
VACCIN, LLY OD NEWS.
GOING TO BE PRETTY
IF YOU'VE BEEN VACCINAD,HAPOU DN
OU SHOGET TESTED
NOW.
REERE SY DON'T
NEED TO GET TESTED.YING EVEN IF
YOU'RE VNAD HA RE YOU
Y TE.R
KEEP IN MIND, LOOK F YOU H
SYMPTO N MATTE
YOU DON'T KNOWF IT'S
THE FLU,
OPLE W SYMPTOMS.
>>F EXPOD,
T YM
CC SO YOU DON'T NEED T
AR YOU HAVE DREN?
IF YOU HLL CHILDN.MALL CHILDREN
ASKI FF.>> -OU HAV
SYMPTOMS OBVIOUSLY ISOLATEHE HO.
ANY SYMPNDU HAVE THEVIRUS, THENT
AS THING LIKE THAT ORSTAY AWAY
YOU'RE WAITID R AT'S T
HT?
IFE WORRIETHINK THATYO
K IS REALLY
IT  NT IT'SQUITE LOW.
N'HASP
LD DO  I TG
THAT I WOULDY GE